talk to me about mr beast so you said
that you guys are gonna do some stuff
with him how do you think about somebody
who i look at athletes are really
interesting but mr beast was born on the
internet he was bred on the internet
he's an internet kind of lovable person
massive audience how do you think about
partnering with somebody like that what
would you guys do with nfts and mr beast
the creative part is amazing i i saw
actually the art few days ago uh so mr
beast is a guy that's
like you said was born on the internet
and i'm very excited for this job
because he's giving away all the money
to charity he's one of the few people
that actually do that you know a lot a
lot of people are interested in web 3
and nfts all of their are financially
incentivized to do that right but mr
beast is different he doesn't really
care about making money out of it so
he's donating all the funds to uh team
c's the campaign has started to remove
trash from the ocean i don't know if you
guys have seen that i'm pretty sure you
have we creating digital characters and
wearables for mr b for mr beast you can
use those wearables in the metaverse and
buy his nfts collectibles and yeah all
the proceeds will go to the team sees
campaign and so when you think about
something like that how much of this is
just uh you're able to buy mr beast uh
nfts and you kind of just hold them
versus it'll actually unlock experiences
or have there be some sort of connection
with the creative art versus some sort
of uh other value so we categorize our
nfts um differently some of them are
unlocking experiences like you get to
zoom with mr beast or you get to meet
him in real life we did this with manny
pacquiao the kid who won the one-on-one
auction we flew him to vegas he watched
the pacquiao fight with ugas he got to
meet him they had the conversation and
and it was pretty fun for him huge
boxing boxing fun but you know some
other some other customers got to get
physical items the pacquiao gloves from
the fight some some of them got the zoom
with manny pacquiao right the same thing
stands for a lot of other talent that we
have on board but it doesn't end there
the wearables and the metaverse stuff
are even more fun for me because you get
to unlock the manny pacquiao gloves and
now you can use them on your avatar on
the metaverse and when i say the
metaverse that doesn't mean only the
authority metaphors because in my
opinion there's not going to be one
metaphor there's going to be thousands
of metaverses right intuba
interpretability i'm sorry in tom how do
you say this word in english
incompatible
no inter interoperability
yeah yeah interoperable it's it's
interoperability is very important
because let's say you bought those
pacquiao gloves through eternity you
should be able to use them on your
avatar on sandbox on the central land or
whatever metaphors you you you like
right so that's what's something we're
really focusing on